le débat de ce club consacré à la
politique migratoire Emmanuel Macron qui
souhaiterait partir les migrants sur
l'ensemble du territoire une décision
qui fait débat on va le voir que pensent
les habitants et les élus des
territoires concernés que faut-il
attendre de la loi immigration et cette
question va-t-elle être au cœur de la
campagne des sénatoriales on va débattre
de tout ça avec vous chaque message
Bruno bonjour bonjour
patriars bonjour merci d'être là vous
êtes président du groupe RDPI au Sénat
et sénateurs de la majorité
présidentielle voilà elle dit pire
Renaissance allez les sénateurs de la
majorité présidentielle même si tout le
monde vous connaît on précise quand même
on va évidemment parler de la politique
migratoire et de ce souhait d'Emmanuel
Macron Audrey manuel Macron qui souhaite
une meilleure répartition des étrangers
dans les espaces ruraux qui sont en
train de perdre de la population je cite
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça s'appelle
l'orientation directive et ça existe
déjà Oriane mais a très petite échelle
d'abord il y a un constat je vais vous
montrer une carte on voit que 46%
des demandeurs d'asile se concentrent en
Île-de-France qui ne représente pourtant
que 19% des capacités d'accueil de notre
territoire on comprend donc que ça
coince alors que vous le voyez aussi il
y a des zones beaucoup plus claires je
regarde la Bourgogne Franche-Comté le
centre Val de Loire et de la Loire ou la
Bretagne l'idée c'est de proposer à ces
demandeurs d'asile principalement des
familles une orientation directive vers
d'autres régions je m'est proposé entre
guillemets car s'il refuse il perd de
leur allocation journalière de
demandeurs d'asile de 14,20 d'après un
rapport d'information de l'Assemblée
nationale très récent ça a concerné
48230 demandeurs d'asile sur les années
2021 et 2022
30402 ont accepté de rejoindre un
nouveau lieu d'hébergement d'après mes
divisions ça représente donc 1270
demandeurs d'asile par mois répartis
dans 10 régions de France les
Hauts-de-Seine n'ont pas d'impératif en
raison de la pression migratoire déjà
observée et la Corse n'a pas de centre
pour demande d'accueil pour demandeurs
d'asile sur son territoire Oriane une
dernière question est-ce que vous savez
de quand date cette idée que le
président veut donc généraliser pas
avant de lire votre chronique maintenant
je le sais parce que j'ai la réponse
des années 70 à l'époque pour accueillir
les réfugiés chiliens qui fuyaient le
coup d'État de Pinochet l'idée prend de
l'ampleur en 2016 sous la houlette de
Bernard Cazeneuve à le ministre de
l'Intérieur
au moment du démantèlement de la jungle
de Calais mais j'ai regardé dans nos
archives et j'ai remarqué que cette idée
avait été défendue un an plus tôt en
2015 donc monsieur patriarche au moment
de la crise des migrants en Europe par
un homme d'un autre bord politique que
Bernard Cazeneuve est-ce que vous saurez
deviner qui sait autour de cette table
pour l'eau non pas loin
un ministre un premier ministre un
ancien Premier ministre l'ancien Premier
ministre Jean-Pierre Raffarin que je
vous propose d'écouter
on ferait en sorte que l'étranger au
lieu de venir déranger il vient sauver
un territoire il participe à une
dynamique et si c'est ta dose qui sont
des doses humainement acceptables par
les uns et par les autres l'intégration
était globalement réussi voilà c'est une
idée qui date chacune de ces genres
c'est pas une bonne idée pour vous mais
le sujet c'est que quand monsieur
Raffarin parlait de ce sujet on en était
pas là où nous en sommes aujourd'hui je
pense qu'on peut pas comparer une
réflexion qu'on peut avoir il y a 15 ou
20 ans qui est effectivement plus ou
moins maîtrisé les flux migrateurs
étaient plus ou moins je l'ai dit
aujourd'hui on a des féminatoires qui ne
sont absolument plus maîtrisés c'est
vrai que vous avez rappelé à juste titre
et moi je suis élu dans la région
parisienne que 50% en gros des
problématiques
des migrations sont concentrées à Paris
en Île-de-France mais mais c'est pas par
hasard vous savez quand vous vous allez
quand voyager vous voyez bien que les
grandes villes et les capitales elles
concentrent l'essentiel des difficultés
par le monde voilà aujourd'hui c'est la
première question qu'il faut se poser
par rapport à parce que vous parlez bien
de demandeurs d'asile voilà on parle de
demandeur d'asile on sait qu'aujourd'hui
de la demande d'asile sont complètement
détourné car tout le monde demande tout
le monde demande un titre d'asile et on
sait très bien que l'essentiel est
débouté donc la question de fond c'est
réformons regardons
comment aujourd'hui on peut gérer ces
demandes d'asile qui ne sont pas remises
en cause en tout cas par nous je veux
dire la France a toujours accueilli
celles et ceux qui étaient
mis en danger dans leur propre et c'est
pas le sujet sauf qu'aujourd'hui cette
demande d'asile elle est totalement
détournée tout le monde allemand donc le
temps que toutes les instructions soient
faites et que les gens soient dégoûtés
ça prend effectivement de plus en plus
de temps sur la répartition la
répartition après ça se fait pas alors
aujourd'hui effectivement on a les Jeux
Olympiques qui arrivent il de Paris soit
beau propre émerveilleux ce qui est pas
tout à fait aujourd'hui bah écoutez
pourquoi c'est énervé là aujourd'hui on
peut se poser la question parce que
c'est pas nouveau quand même les gens
qui dorment sur le trottoir moi je pense
qu'il y a rien de satisfaisant à Paris
d'avoir des gens qui dort sur une
réalité qui n'est pas d'hier donc
aujourd'hui on veut répartir mais
d'abord ça ne peut pas se faire sans
l'accord des mères ça ne peut pas se
faire sans que les mères soient informés
ça ne peut pas se faire tant qu'il n'y a
pas de projet de territoire parce que
allez mettre à l'abri pour effectivement
faire en sorte que des gens dorment dans
d'autres lieux que des trottoirs
parisiens j'entends mais pour faire quoi
comment repeupler les villages d'abord
ce mot je ne supporte pas qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire repeupler les villages
enfin je veux dire c'est c'est pas une
belle enfin je trouve que c'est pas une
belle phrase et ça doit se faire avec un
projet territoire avec les élus parce
que mettre à l'abri c'est bien mais
est-ce qu'il y a après des possibilités
de logement des possibilités d'emploi
difficulté que nous avons en
Île-de-France parce que c'est une
réalité voilà donc tout ça et vraiment
joli mais tout ça c'est une espèce de
façade qui veut cacher une vraie
difficulté d'intégration de ces vagues
migratoires et de ces personnes qui sont
ici dont on ne sait pas quoi faire
c'est d'abord l'expérience montre et
j'ai l'expérience de mon village de 1600
habitants qui a été installé il y a 6
ans qui ne pose aucun problème
aujourd'hui première chose donc voyez en
Bourgogne donc vous avez ok il y en a et
il y a eu des difficultés au départ il y
a eu des manifestations le RN est venu
manifester il y a eu des gens le maire
était très courageux il a assumé
situation la population est beaucoup de
bénévoles s'en sont occupés et ça
fonctionne non déjà les CADA il y en
aura sur d'anti régions en France il
s'agit pas de repeupler je pense pas que
l'objectif de repeuplé soit le réel il
s'agit dans un premier temps de mettre à
l'abri des gens qui sont en situation
difficile et en danger il s'agit de
mieux traiter plus vite leur document
administratif il s'agit d'apporter des
solutions en fin de compte de savoir où
on les traite après certains qui sont
demandeurs d'asile seront dans des sites
adéquats ceux qui sont aussi irrégulière
vont dans des structures qui sont faits
pour les régulières et ceux qui sont en
occutaires doivent être expulsés et
partis et là c'est difficile je vais
vous la connais alors quand vous dites
maîtriser c'était plus maîtrisé non
c'était pas plus maîtrisé il y a 20 ans
il y a pas de plus de maîtrise c'est
qu'il y avait beaucoup moins d'immigrés
parce que le changement climatique parce
que les flux migratoires étaient moins
longs étaient pas plus ça l'a jamais été
maîtrisé réellement et alors on peut
avoir deux choses un il y a d'abord le
phénomène que l'on constate tous une
immigration massive importante qui
augmente le côté le traitement pour moi
faut-il les traiter faut-il les traiter
humainement ou inhumainement la solution
qui est proposée elle est faite avec des
associations bénévoles sur le territoire
avec une présence 24 heures sur 24 avec
un accompagnateur pour 15 personnes ce
sont des solutions transitoires ce que
j'ai pu voir chez moi c'est que la
population des élus municipaux des gens
s'occupent des gens à prendre le
français son bénévole ça crée des
problèmes dans les écoles madame oui
c'est vrai on a eu des problèmes dans
les écoles en voyant arriver beaucoup de
jeunes de la Corne de l'Afrique qui sont
arrivés mais il n'empêche que ce qui
s'est passé à Saint-Brevin est
dramatique c'est un épi phénomène sur le
panel c'est un phénomène dramatique dans
beaucoup de cas où ça se passe pas si
mal que ça
vous me parlez d'une expérience d'un
petit village une quinzaine de glucins
de personnes mais on en est plus là
j'entends bien mais on en est plus là je
veux dire on en est plein moi je suis
persuadé qu'à Paris on est incapable de
nous donner le chiffre de demandeurs
d'Asie de personnes en situation
régulière enfin quand on vit à Paris on
voit bien la difficulté que nous avons à
gérer cette problématique d'étrangers en
situation irrégulière dont on ne sait
pas quoi faire vous vous évidemment dans
un petit village quand vous avez 60
personnes à gérer et que la population
fait l'objectif
comment vous allez gérer ces milliers
ces milliers de personnes qui sont alors
il y a Paris qui en concentré énormément
mais il y a pas que Paris vous avez la
même chose dans des grandes villes de
province à Toulouse à Marseille partout
partout à Bordeaux il y a des
difficultés à Lyon n'en parlons pas donc
je veux dire on
[Musique]
quelle est la gouvernement en matière
pas elle date de 2017 alors maintenant
ça se passe mieux c'est ce que nous
expliquer François Patriat mais au début
chez vous aussi ça ne s'est pas très
bien passé
bonjour oui exactement bon on nous a
imposé ces migrants sans aucune
concertation sans aucune discussion
l'État a décidé d'acheter un insigne
Formule 1 et du jour au lendemain
aujourd'hui avertis comme quoi en allant
le recevoir une centaine de migrants
lorsque j'ai eu cette bonne nouvelle
j'ai demandé tout de suite rendez-vous à
Monsieur le Préfet monsieur bouillon qui
m'accordait ce rendez-vous et j'ai
organisé rapidement avec ma population
qui était comme on peut l'imaginer
contre cette ce projet
nous avons fait une réunion publique où
là les gens ont exprimé leur inquiétude
leur peur
le fait qu'on nous impose ça sans aucune
discussion d'une façon très autoritaire
Monsieur le Préfet a répondu à toutes
les questions et bon à relativement
calmer l'atmosphère qui était vraiment
un bon très tendu
actuellement actuellement ces migrants
sont là ils sont situés dans un parc
d'activités à peu près 3 km du
centre-ville ceux qui n'est pas le plus
gênant
ils ont les transports ils partent
beaucoup sur les villes voisines les
grandes villes qui sont au panneau
Marseille donc nous chez nous ça se
passe relativement bien voilà mais c'est
vrai que j'ai constaté que nous avons
plus de lignes c'est à dire que il y a
plus de lignes ni avec la préfecture ni
avec qui que ce soit c'est à dire que
ces gens-là sont là c'est pas le nombre
exact c'est pas leur nom on ne sait pas
leur origine nous sommes dans le plus
complet et on est ici à gérer cette
difficulté de la façon la plus
sympathique voilà ce que je veux dire
rester avec nous on va faire réagir
François Patriat et Jacqueline salvinho
qui auront peut-être d'ailleurs des
questions à vous poser François Patriat
quand vous entendez ça d'abord le
problème de méthode et puis les
difficultés actuelles
la façon dont ça c'est passé à Gémenos
salut Monsieur le Maire de Gémenos c'est
la même façon que ça s'est passé dans la
commune où j'habite le maire a été
prévenu qui avait d'anciens locaux
gendarmerie au bord de l'autoroute qui
était libre on a mis dans le genre de le
maire au lieu de immédiatement il faut
des populations a pris choses il y a eu
un accompagnement
[Musique]
on a prévenu nous en disant vous avez
des locaux nous allons les installer
chez vous et prévu de pouvoir récupérer
ce locaux on va le faire travailler
ensemble et nous avons travaillé
ensemble la préfète le préfet la
sous-préfet de son du travail avec nous
les forces de l'ordre aussi travailler
avec nous quand il y a eu quelques
difficultés au départ non mais ce que je
veux dire le problème non c'est d'agit
il s'agit pas de mettre 60 par ci par là
il s'agit de mieux répartir sur le
territoire des gens qui sont concentrés
aujourd'hui dans une région parce que si
bien je lis de dire il faut supprimer la
colline du crack mais où on met les gens
parce que moi moi j'entends bien
j'entends bien un homme le constat que
vous faites on peut le partager
j'entends bien les récriminations que
vous avez je les entends mais j'attends
vos solutions j'attends vos solutions
alors si vos solutions bien entendu
elles seront les mêmes que nous c'est
d'empêcher l'immigration massive
d'accord mais après donnez-moi la
solution pour mieux traiter sur les
immigrés qui arrivent en France au
détriment des drames qui est arrivé la
semaine dernière ça peut satisfaire qui
qui est 80 personnes qui me rendèrent
comme hier parce qu'on peut pas crier
est-ce qu'on peut pas parfois un
sentiment d'humanité un peu malgré tout
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait des gens qui
arrivent sinon de trouver les solutions
pérennes je vous rappelle quand même des
chiffres dans les livres d'urgence
depuis 1000 depuis 2015 et 700 lits
d'urgence compte par mois il y en a eu
22000 créés par ce gouvernement 22000
c'est dur d’accueil d'urgence en 2022 et
maintenant c'est 2000 personnes par mois
qui vont aller vers la province voilà
non mais on peut pas
j'entends vous me parlez des drames et
qui peut se satisfaire des drames en
Méditerranée c'est pas le sujet c'est
pas le sujet aujourd'hui d'abord
Monsieur le Maire là il a bien expliqué
on lui a pas demandé son avis on lui a
imposé donc voilà enfin la réalité elle
est là c'est si vous estimez que quand
on vous dit il y a 100 100 hommes parce
qu'en général il y a que des hommes sans
personne sans homme souvent il y a quand
même que des hommes on va bien Marie ce
qui se passe il y a essentiellement des
hommes mais bon il y a pas que des
hommes il y a essentiellement bon bah
vous allez avoir demain chez vous une
centaine de personnes dans des seuls
locaux j'appelle pas ça de la
concertation c'est une méthode on vous
l'impose et vous faites avec et là
exactement expliqué Monsieur le Maire ce
qui se passe c'est à dire que cette
population une fois qu'on l'a que l'État
et ça va se passer comme ça partout
l'État va peut-être faire de la
concertation un peu mieux qu'avant parce
qu'avant il y en avait pas pour dire
vous allez accueillir 50 60 migrants et
après l'État s'en va on voit bien ce
maire il s'est il gère plus il connaît
pas la population qui est dans sa
commune mais elle est gérée
financièrement par l'État pas pour leur
donner un toit point c'est moi j'appelle
pas ça
ne connaît même pas le statut des gens
qui sont là est-ce qu'ils ont été
déboutés de droit d'asile est-ce qu'ils
ont le droit de rester encore là et de
toute façon dans la journée ils vont
comme je les ai tout à l'heure dans les
grandes villes parce que dans les
villages une en dehors du fait de les
héberger ce qui est déjà bien pourquoi
pas c'est pas le sujet il vieux viennent
quoi est-ce qu'il y a du travail dans ce
village est-ce qu'il y a des solutions
de sortie pour les héberger dans ce
village une fois par exemple qu'ils ont
qui sont qui sont leurs dossier d'asile
et qui sont reconnus ils vont pas rester
l'un définitivement il faut les reloger
il faut leur donner du boulot est-ce que
dans ces villages il y en a probablement
bas et donc ils vont dans les grandes
villes et on en rajoute dans les grandes
villes périphériques parce qu'on a un
problème global de d'une immigration qui
est de moins en moins maîtrisée nous
accueillons des flux migratoires pas
uniquement des pays d'Afrique du Nord
moi dans le Val-d'Oise il y a des
communautés qui viennent de tous les
pays donc avec lequel on n'a pas de lien
particulier donc voilà donc c'est ça la
réalité c'est qu'on peut pas se
contenter de leur dire on leur donne à
toi point puis après débrouiller
ce qu'on pense le maire François patri a
20 ans qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce
que ce que vient de dire François
Patriat et Jacqueline ne se fait jouir
Monsieur le Maire bon moi je pense c'est
vrai que ces gens-là sont laissés appris
à eux-mêmes bon hein nous localement il
y a une association qui s'est créée et
j'ai un bénévole qui justement s'occupe
de ces gens-là et à part ces bénévoles
je ne pense pas que ces gens soient pris
en charge c'est un peu livrés eux-mêmes
bon après je colle au bois mais c'est
très difficile de juger puisque on n'a
pas de d'information c'est heureusement
heureusement qu'il y a des gens
bénévoles qui s'en occupent aussi la
Croix-Rouge qui leur permet d'écrire et
de s'intégrer difficilement mais de
s'intégrer alors je pense aussi que vous
voyez je pense aussi que la théorie et
la réalité c'est souvent deux choses
différentes
mais après il faut voir dans quel état
sont les logements quel est leur
occupation journalière quels font-ils
toute la journée je crois que ce genre
de question il faut se poser parce que
c'est peut-être dans cette voie qu'on
pourra résoudre le problème et puis
ensuite je crois il faut y aller nous je
vous cache pas que ça se passe
relativement bien comme je vous le
disais ça se passe bien parce que le
lieu est vraiment excentré et ces
gens-là préfèrent aller dans la grande
ville ou dans les grandes villes pour
trouver certains occupations qui n'ont
pas dans mon village merci Monsieur le
Maire merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous moi je voulais savoir
est-ce que ce sont essentiellement des
hommes ou ce qu'il y a des femmes et des
hommes ou est-ce que ce sont
essentiellement des hommes
alors au début c'était que des hommes et
ensuite là actuellement mais je vous dis
bon par rapport à ce que l'on sait bon
c'est pas
on a quelques couples et nous avons
quand même
scolariser les enfants
au frais de la collectivité
parce que c'est un droit et donc on a
quelques enfants qui ont été intégrés
dans les écoles paternelles et primaires
merci il doit y avoir à peu près 3 ou 4
couples d'accord merci merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous un Roland Gilberti
merde de Gémenos dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône on va aller en
Ille-et-Vilaine maintenant voir un autre
exemple du côté de brume ou là la
mobilisation de la population et
peut-être à l'origine du fait que
finalement l'État est revenu sur son
projet on voit ça c'est Fabien Ricard
qui s'est rendu sur place
c'est un terrain en friche appartenant à
la SNCF en mars dernier l'état informe
le maire de la commune de Bruz qu'il va
construire ici un centre d'hébergement
pour migrants et sans abri venus de la
région parisienne c'est cette parcelle
là en fait qui serait qui serait retenu
il y a pas d'ombre il y a pas d'armes
puisque c'est pour lui donc il y a rien
qui pousse à part quelques herbes coincé
entre une voie ferrée et un pont routier
sur lequel passe plusieurs milliers de
voitures par jour le terrain est pollué
aux hydrocarbures et aux métaux lourds
impensable pour le maire d'y accueillir
50 personnes dont des enfants comme le
prévoit leur la préfecture Bru comme la
Bretagne c'est une terre d'accueil je
veux dire on a toujours été une terre
d'accueil d'ailleurs on accueille nous
aussi des immigrés les exilés des
personnes qui sont en attente de
régularisation de leur situation on n'a
jamais dit qu'on voulait pas accueillir
de de personnes simplement on veut les
accueillir dans des conditions dignes
pendant plusieurs semaines Philippe
salmon tente de faire valoir ses
arguments auprès de l'État sans succès
mais quelques minutes après notre
interview coup de théâtre un communiqué
de la préfecture vient de tomber on
vient de recevoir un communiqué de
presse de la part de la préfecture donc
le secrétaire général adjoint m'a envoyé
ce communiqué de presse constatant que
l'emprise foncière SNCF de Bruz d'abord
envisagé nécessiterait de trop lourds
investissements notamment du fait de la
pollution du terrain l'État a décidé de
ne pas recourir à cette parcelle ça veut
pas dire que l'État cherche pas encore
il cherche effectivement il est bien
indiqué un foncier appartenant à l'État
sur le territoire de la métropole le
soir même monsieur le maire a invité les
habitants à une réunion d'information
nous est arrivé cet après-midi la
préfecture a renoncé à mettre sous ça
c'est l'hébergement sur le terrain SNCF
on n'est pas non plus sortie de la
boucle on dit comme les 43 autres
communes si le site de la SNCF est
abandonné le centre d'hébergement verra
donc le jour sur un autre lieu du
territoire la commune voisine de
Montgermont vient d'ailleurs
d'accueillir provisoirement un premier
groupe de 100 abris dans la salle
certaines voies se montrent plutôt
hostiles à l'arrivée de nouveaux
migrants il y a pas les capacités des
structures d'hébergement il y a
visiblement pas les conditions d'accueil
et de formation qui devraient être
actées pour pour l'accueil de ces
gens-là la plupart des habitants
reprochent surtout à l'état une méthode
brutale c'est très dommageable pour les
intéresser eux-mêmes on a vraiment
l'impression de paquets qu'on déplace
d'un endroit à un autre pour que la
Ville de Paris soit propre au moment des
Jeux Olympiques et humainement c'est
juste inacceptable l'association locale
d'accueil des réfugiés redoute quant à
elle par son action mise à mal par un
projet mal préparé sans aucun travail
préalable on a appris comme ça que un
sas allait être installé avec 50
personnes toutes les trois semaines à
débarqué dans la plus grande dans la
plus grande préparation nous comme
association tout le travail associatif
qu'on fait avec des initiatives de ce
type ça remet beaucoup en cause et ça
prend de plein fouet tout ce qu'on a pu
mettre en place sur la commune dans son
projet le gouvernement prévoit 500
places d'hébergement répartis dans 10
régions et veut éviter le retour à Paris
des personnes déplacées en Bretagne
comme ailleurs il va falloir user de
plus de pédagogie
vous entendez François Patriat c'est le
problème de méthode l'inquiétude des
habitants alors première chose sur la
méthode en l'occurrence l'État a préparé
son erreur c'est vrai préparer hâtif mal
préparé il s'est rendu à la raison
lorsque les arguments quand il y a de
bons arguments ici un seul pollué
déshydrocarbures une emprise entre les
serres entre la loi pour l'État dit à la
fin effectivement vous avez raison on va
chercher ailleurs mais ce que dit des
habitants dans le même temps disent
écoutez c'est comme les prisons les
prisons il faut beaucoup plus de prison
en France mais pas chez nous pas chez
nous donc les immigrés bah faut pas mal
les accueillir mais pas chez nous
j'entends bien or je réponds à Madame
Stach aussi que quand les gens
deviennent en situation régulière et
c'est arrivé chez moi trouve du travail
à la campagne il y a besoin de bras il y
a des artisans des menuisiers des
plombiers des charpentiers du BTP qui
cherchent des gens et ces gens-là
trouvent du travail et moi maintenant je
vois dans mon village des gens qui
étaient arrivés toi qui ont été
naturalisés qui accueillis dont
maintenant il y a des femmes et des
enfants dans la commune qui vont qui
vont à l'école bien sûr ça pose quelques
problèmes mais enfin c'est une solution
parce que moi je veux bien qu'on refuse
celle-là qui est une solution qui me
paraît pas pour dégager parler de jeux
olympiques on voit bien à Paris ce qui
se passe sous les ponts on a vu avant
hier soir les gens qu'on a mis devant le
Conseil d'État vous avez vu dramatique
il faut éviter les situations de
dramatique il faut mettre les gens hors
de danger en amour à quoi ça répond ça à
traiter plus humainement des gens qui
aujourd'hui sont en danger
bien sûr que ça pose toujours des
problèmes on est bien d'accord mais ce
que je veux voir c'est les solutions en
dehors des solutions aujourd'hui de
stopper l'immigration d'aller mieux
traiter les pays dans les pays d'où ils
viennent de freiner l'arrivée d'accord
mais après j'attends de l'opposition
qu'elle nous donne des des solutions
peut-être meilleur mais j'attends
toujours les propositions alors moi je
voudrais revenir sur un chiffre qu'on a
entendu à la fin de votre portable
l'état prévoit 500 places
500 j'ai entendu le chiffre 500 il y en
a combien à Paris des milliers d'accord
donc on nous fait une espèce de
politique poudre aux yeux pour 500
places en province parce que de toute
façon il y a pas il y a très peu
d'équipements qui sont prêts pour les
accueillir rapidement alors qu'il y a
des milliers et des milliers de
personnes à sur Paris en situation ou de
son papier ou de demander un asile donc
c'est un sens et la poudre aux yeux du
gouvernement voilà après tout à l'heure
chers collègues vous avez je pense que
c'était peut-être pas le meilleur
argument
parler de la colline du crack en disant
je suis sûr que quand les élus de
province vont se dire on va peut-être
recevoir les toxicos et trafiquants de
crack à Paris je suis pas sûr qu'ils
sont ravis de les accueillir parce que
tout à l'heure
vous faites le rapprochement mais c'est
vous qui avez dit la colline de
aladjubère régler la police la colline
du crack avant les Jeux Olympiques parce
que c'est vrai que c'est pas une belle
image de Paris non mais clairement
clairement il y a tout ça derrière parce
que moi je veux bien que on se voilà on
se renvoie là-bas par exemple sur la
colline du crack revenant là-dessus
entre la mairie de Paris qui veut se
confronter au gouvernement et c'est pas
très malin non plus sur ce sujet là mais
la coloning là qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on
a déplacé dans Paris mais ils sont
toujours là le réseau on connaît très
bien les réseaux de trafic du crack on
sait très bien qu'il y a derrière on a
fait quoi donc voilà le problème c'est
que cette espèce de politique de dire on
va prendre le sujet à bras le corps et
puis quand on va au bout bah il se passe
rien moi je répète eu en dehors des Jeux
Olympiques quelle est la ligne du
gouvernement en matière migratoire pour
que à court moyen et long terme on en
soit plus là parce que je sais très bien
qu'on va pas régler ça en trois jours
mais quelle est la volonté aujourd'hui
pour faire qu'effectivement Paris Paris
vous savez l'image de Paris c'est
dégradée
les touristes à Paris il y a pas une
femme qui a pas son sac devant parce
qu'il y a un lien entre l'immigration et
voilà même si c'est pas si ça plaît pas
la question que vous lui posez quelle
est la politique du gouvernement
j'essaie de reprendre les arguments à
part à nos messages première argument
vous dites en fin de compte ça va être
600 personnes que c'est 610
alors d'un côté vous dites c'est
dramatique on voyait les gens la
campagne vous rendez pas compte les gens
vont être malheureux puis après vous
dites maintenant c'est pas grave il y en
axissant non faut savoir est-ce que
c'est grave qui au début vous avez dit
on va envoyer les gens là-bas bon est-ce
que c'est grave puis après vous dites
c'est pas grave il y en a pas beaucoup
ensuite j'ai dit c'est de la poudre aux
yeux c'est différent c'est la même chose
non pas du tout la même chose pas du
tout ensuite ensuite vous dites vous
dites qu'est-ce que fait l'état qui est
de la politique je viens de vous le dire
Madame
22000 places d'hébergement créées en
2022 je trouvais pas qu'une politique
qu'est-ce qui a fait est-ce que vous
avez fait aussi bien à l'époque
22000 places en 2022 7 à 800 par mois
aujourd'hui et on va envoyer là c'est
pour 3000 c'est 2000 personnes 2000
personnes par mois qui vont partir dans
les SAS 2000 personnes par mois c'est
pas si simple c'est 2000 par mois alors
voyez c'est ça le chiffre aujourd'hui
donc il faut mais j'attends toujours
madame stage je vous entends constater
je vous entends critiquer je vous
entends parler un peu à tort des Jeux
olympiques mais j'attends toujours vos
solutions ah non mais donnez-nous une
solution nous on a alors c'est facile
dans l'opposition
c'est on assume notre place et nous
avons fait des propositions en matière
de loi immigration on attend que on en a
fait le projet de loi immigration il a
été repoussé X fois que le gouvernement
on y est pour rien nous dans dans le
projet Asie l'immigration on a proposé
des choses très claires on verra ce que
le gouvernement veut décider veut
inscrire dans cette loi qui devrait nous
arriver au mois d'octobre on verra bien
c'est pas une solution face aux gens qui
sont dans Paris il faut bien une
solution et vous allez aller dire aux
gens dans Paris attendez on va déposer
une loi ça va aller beaucoup mieux après
vous n'allez pas régler vous n'allez pas
régler si trois jours parce que les Jeux
Olympiques arrivent 10 ans de laxisme
sur l'immigration dans ce pays ça fait
plus de 10 ans qu'on dit à tous les
migrants venaient en France une fois que
vous êtes arrivés vous repartez jamais
c'est quand même ce qui se passe
non mais regardez les chiffres non mais
regardez les Ch'tis Madame Moustache
dans les chiffres moi moi je suis
objectif dans les chiffres regardez les
chiffres on n'a jamais eu autant de
demandeurs d'Asie on a jamais dû autant
de flux migratoires et on n'a jamais
autant de gens qui se disent une fois
qu'on est à Paris on ne part jamais
c'est ça la dragué ne faisons pas espèce
de poudre aux yeux en disant on va en
mettre quelques uns en province pour
régler le problème des Jeux Olympiques
parce que Monsieur Darmanin a dit qu'il
y aurait plus aucun problème de
délinquance pendant les Jeux Olympiques
tant mieux pour Paris mais voilà nous
réglons pas ça comme ça c'est quand même
pour terminer on va écouter Marine Le
Pen parce qu'elle elle fait de cette
question de la répartition des migrants
un thème de la campagne sénatoriale et
elle appelle les maires les élus locaux
a voté pour les candidats du RN on
écoute
le Pacte des migration de l'Union
européenne proposait d'instaurer dans
toute l'Europe des relocalisations
forcées de migrants et bien Emmanuel
Macron annonce vouloir l'imposer sans
attendre dans toute la France dans le
moindre village le plus reculé dans le
moindre hameau nous sommes prévenus
l'immigration submersion c'est eux qui
l'a choisi mais c'est vous qui la
subirez ce mépris pour les élus locaux
cette négation de l'identité
territoriale de vos communes jamais des
sénateurs du rassemblement national ne
l'accepterait est-ce que cette
proposition est faite
d'abord parce qu'ils sont mensonges
d'abord parce qu'ils sont caricaturaux
caricaturaux et ensuite que c'est le
fonds de commerce de Madame Le Pen je
regrette madame le stage contenant les
propos boutonnés avant vous alimentez le
discours de madame
vous avez dit tout à l'heure nous pour
nous les SAS c'est pas une solution
c'est ce qu'elle dit et vous dites quand
même si vous avez pas dit que c'est la
poudre aux yeux c'est pas une solution
dans la stratégie globale de la pétine
gratuit
il y a deux choses il y a le traitement
d'urgence de gens en situation
dramatique de gens situation irrégulière
qu'il faut faire et le gouvernement qui
attaque à bras le et puis comment est-ce
que vous dites comme solution comment il
s'attaque à bras le corps aujourd'hui je
pense que aujourd'hui d'abord on excuse
beaucoup plus de gens du temps vous
étiez au gouvernement beaucoup plus de
gens beaucoup plus trois fois plus on
explique plus 3 mais si c'est vrai trois
fois
je vous donne des chiffres vraie ensuite
madame je veux dire je vous donne vous
dites ça pour le traitement d'urgence et
ensuite pour l'avenir une loi mais il y
a une loi qui est Monsieur Darmanin
prépare et une loi qui est équilibrée et
efficace et qui va rendre et parce que
vous vous êtes dans la loi extrême
aujourd'hui vous voulez supprimer la me
plus rien du tout vous voulez qu'il n'y
ait pas de gens qui viennent s'installer
ici parce que il y aura des contrats de
travail futur vous ne voulez pas c'est
une ligne rouge donc je vois bien dans
votre loi votre loi elle est excessive
inapplicable et contraire au droit de
l'homme
elle est surtout réaliste et elle tient
compte de la réalité de ce qui se passe
dans ce pays sans sans dogme et sans
voilà vous voulez faire une politique de
régularisation ça c'est la ligne rouge
dans le magasin vous savez venez dans le
Val-d'Oise vous allez voir ce que vous
allez faire en régularisant tous les
écosystèmes qui sont dans nos
gouvernement comme ils l'ont fait agir
avec le regroupement familial et nous on
a une responsabilité c'est le chantage
n'existe pas en matière d'immigratoire
et nous tiendrons cette ligne et nous
avons effectivement des propositions
concrètes pour essayer de d'endiguer ce
phénomène et qui favorise le Fond
national d'ailleurs vous ne réglez
toujours pas le problème actuel avec
évidemment c'est un sujet qui va qui va
continuer donc c'est normal dans le
débat politique on regarde si elle est
une de nos quotidiens les gens
voudraient
[Musique]
et encore une fois c'est le climat la
météo à la une de nos quotidiens avec un
chiffre d'abord
41,6 c'est la température enregistrée
hier à l'ombrage Ajaccio un record pour
un mois de juin nous apprend Corse-Matin
un épisode de canicule généré par un
coût de Sirocco une chape de plomb qui
coïncide avec un pic de pollution aux
particules fines causé par les
poussières venues du Sahara rien que ça
tout devrait revenir à la normale avec
des pluies attendus aujourd'hui ça c'est
ce qui se passe actuellement la Dépêche
du Midi s'interroge aussi sur ce qui
pourrait se passer plus tard avec ce
titre orage et si le pire était à venir
ces phénomènes violents et très
localisés risques de se répéter et c'est
ici que les supercalculateurs de Météo
France entre en jeu ils tiennent mieux
compte du relief de la nature des sols
pour resserrer les prévisions à quelques
dizaines de kilomètres autre quotidien
autre prévisions le Dauphiné Libéré joue
l'anticipation en se demandant à quoi
ressemblerait l'Isère avec 4 degrés de
plus puisque c'est le scénario annoncé
pour 2100 c'est pas réjouissant un
climat méditerranéen dans les montagnes
des pics de chaleur entre 45 et 50
degrés et la disparition des glaciers à
90% et puis Oriane je vais terminer par
une idée d'activité pour finir sur une
note de lit légèreté c'est le retour des
joutes sur le doux sachez que ça fait
partie de l'histoire locale ça remonte
au Second Empire je vous rappellerai
rapidement les règles puisque vous avez
peut-être envie d'y aller ce weekend
lorsque deux embarcations arrivent à
proximité il faut faire tomber
l'adversaire avec un plastron tout est à
faire de technique et danse dissipation
nous explique le Journal de
Saône-et-Loire voilà
on vient de le faire
vidéo d'avoir été avec nous merci Audrey
on se retrouve demain et pour voir ou
revoir ce débat et cette émission c'est
sur notre site internet public sénat.fr
très bonne journée à demain
[Musique]